yeah welcome to this video 1e Falls
played and let's go for this and I'm not
trying to pronounce it again so we've
got the Lacan defense on something and
okay the c6 line Bishop d3 yeah I don't
really know how this is all played but
the 97 looks normal how do you play here
with black yeah probably just g6
shouldn't be too bad yeah this is a
rather typical position from the modern
lines of of this defense the Alec on
this kind of position it's very typical
why it's got the bishops but like gum
has gotten yeah very very solid
structure where it is a difficult for
why to UM make any substantial progress
you can try to play on the Kings side of
it exactly like this but um it's a
question that's questionable if this
really am is some so beneficial in fact
there is not nothing nothing great that
white can do in this position type
but this also applies for black
admittedly black is just if you want to
put it this way em it's just standing
around and keeping the position at item
at status quo it's not like black has
any em big active possibilities okay
here we went for deform interesting and
not bad i mean maybe i should have
played this differently h5 coming out
looks looks really dangerous and f5 has
a really really terrible concession to
move like this ok i don't really see
what else i should do
yeah this didn't really work out I'm
trying to play a huge variety of
openings to make sure that it it's not
the same kind of position all over again
in the videos but it's sometimes just
leads to trouble admittedly okay and
what about rook is 6 cm to defend Bishop
g7 just King g7 and it's not much
happening this is the cell probably this
maybe not so bad I mean I'm threatening
rook g6 crook h6 and so on so he needs
to react in some way i also have to
check now brooke g6 check isn't this
good he goes King everyone I've got
Quincy for so and that this would put
him in an awkward in an awkward pin of
course this Queen age a checkmate so I
need to pay attention to that but this
still looks like like we had a kind of
pin that is in so just grab this and now
I'm use the rope here so it's am
it's not very comfortable cannot move
the King really a take and what is he
moving so some way to to make use of of
all this porn-wise it is equal my rookie
6 doesn't really help much so don't
really see how to how to use this it
looks really nice this kind of pinning
scenario maybe maybe this and rook f6
here to get to to to the FL
so oh come on in there must be something
in this position it's really I cannot
believe that that there shouldn't be a
some continuation leading to an
advantage I mean I see enough stuff like
this that it's probably all right but I
mean the draw is not not the issue but
maybe maybe it is even an issue
unbelievable crap and then to around 20
seconds this is really a really awful
check
yeah I didn't find a winner this is this
is really awful it said there was
something it's it's it's clear yeah okay
of course you can just promote the porn
well this is simply this must be better
for black I mean this cannot be look II
to e6 yeah I played this one later and
now I cannot come on there must be some
new here hmm this are played computer
also doesn't find it when maybe it is
really just the draw I mean the draw is
no issue at all I mean it can look aged
6 everything's fine but there isn't
there isn't a win it seems yeah this
also is okay this king a queen e 1 is
not good need to take on me to
immediately okay but I was down on 22nd
I spend all my time trying to try to
find find a win
it just seems to be a draw i thought
there must be something because this
situation with this king and this pin
looks so awkward but maybe it is so it
is ok rook g2e 6 yeah of course I
thought about that but just Queen g5 I
don't know it still seems a bit weird
yeah well it sometimes happens you're
trying to find a window manage and then
then you like the time to to actually
draw at the end yeah thanks for watching